one thing you'll hear or you'll see
referred to a lot is something called a
flowchart either in computer science or
really when people talk about any type
of algorithm or process so what i
thought i would do is for every program
i write is write a little simple
flowchart maybe i won't do it for
everyone but i'll start with some of the
basic ones just so we understand that a
flow chart really isn't anything fancy
so in this factorial program that we had
been looking at the last couple of
videos so let me any flows chart you're
just going to be kind of with the
starting point which is usually started
i guess
depicted with a circle or an oval of
some kind so we start you can kind of
view it as we're starting at this line
above this assignment of the number
where we actually ask for an input from
the you from the user and then after
that
after that we ask for input from the
user this line right here we are asking
for input from the user
so this right over here and we will
depict that by a parallelogram
so that is input from the user and then
we could just say number
number equals user input
user input and you can be a little bit
loosey-goosey with the terminology here
you're really just trying to say what
you're doing at this step the
parallelogram tells us that we are
somehow interfacing with the user we're
either taking something from the user or
we're outputting something to the user
so here we're saying user input is equal
to number we're signing number as the
user input
then
the next thing we do is just a straight
up operation we just set product to be
equal to one
so we just set and there we just do that
in a rectangle
product equals one
product
product is equal to one
and then something interesting is is
going to happen
we enter into our for loop and we start
with and what i'm going to do here is
i'm going to write it a little bit
different than we wrote it over here so
we do is
we start a
what we're doing is we're going to start
our for loop essentially with an
assignment where we assign for loop is
really a bunch of things happening at
the same time it assigns
i to the first number in the sequence
and then it or it tests whether it can
assign i to the first number in the
sequence if it can then it proceeds if
it can't then it breaks out of the for
loop so
let me put it this way i will do this i
will do kind of a test case right over
here
so items left in sequence so items
items left
in sequence and when i'm referring to
the sequence i'm talking about this
sequence here the range of our number in
the case in the example i gave the last
video the number was three so items left
in this sequence i know it's hard to
read right over here
if there are so let's say that there are
items left in sequence
so if there are items left in sequence
so we'll just say i is equal to next
item i is equal to next
i is equal to the next item
if there are well i'll just i'll just
hold off for the case where there are no
items left in the sequence but let's say
that there are i is equal to the next
item and then we also define
we define product to be
we define product actually i wanted to
do these in blue just our regular
our regular so let me write this as yes
if there are items in the sequence then
then i
is equal to the next item
that's one operation we do and then we
reset product
we reassign product to be equal to what
the former value of product was
times
times i plus 1 times i plus 1
times i plus 1.
and at this point
and at this point we essentially
we loop back to this test over here so
at this point we loop back i'll try to
write it neatly we loop back to let me
do it right over here
we loop back to this point in the
program that's why it is called a loop
because after you perform
after you perform this operation this is
embedded in the loop you go back to the
beginning to see if there's any more of
the loop to do
so you go back to the beginning before
the loop and you say hey are there any
items in the sequence and this should be
a question mark over here these kind of
question mark decision points are you
you specify with this diamond if there
is another item in the sequence then i
is equal to the next item and product is
equal to what product was put times i
plus one we go to the next are there
items left in the sequence and at some
point there won't be any items left in
the sequence
so there won't be at some point there
won't be any items left in sequence and
we could go to the right or i'll just
break out of it down here
i'll just break that out of it down here
and now we've broken out of this for
loop we've broken out of this for loop
and the next thing we do once we're done
with our for loop is we just print the
the value of product we just output the
value of product so that is an
interaction with the user so we are
literally just outputting the value of
product
so we output
output
product
and we are done and i can write end for
the end of my for the end of our program
and the program will stop running
end so this is just a simple flowchart
for this simple program and hopefully it
helps you appreciate that one well one a
little understanding of the program
itself if the last two videos didn't
help too much and also gives you a
simple understanding of how to write a
flowchart